are your teen daughters extreme sports
enthusiasts or just really athletic
perhaps it's time they consider a future
career as a stunt performer
rocky spoke with hollywood stunt woman
and coordinator lafay baker who has a
new program
just for them you have a really special
program
that starts today and it is for it is
preparing young women who are interested
in the stunt field right
right correct so actually the program
is called skin champions and workshops
and what it is we want to educate young
girls about thinking outside the box
actually thinking about being a stunt
woman because right now we have very few
people of color that are actually you
know working as step women and
i think in entertainment industry
there's a lack of diversity behind the
scene and by me
actually being a stunt performer and
growing up in the inner city i think
it's my responsibility
to give back and educate young kids
about these careers
what does it take to be a stunt woman in
hollywood or anywhere
well actually the first thing you need
to be athletically inclined and you
definitely have to have the mind of
determination discipline
and also you know in hollywood there's a
lot of rejection so you can't give up
for sure you've inspired me to do that
my whole life too so thank you
and let's get to the program how did it
come about um the skin champion program
well what happened was there was a
situation where i received a call from
gold bond
and you know goldmine that's the product
line i think they do powder and a couple
of lotions and all that
and they were doing a they want to do a
special with the celebrity or whatever
so
they didn't tell me who the celebrity
was at first they just said we gotta say
once we lock everything and we'll tell
you who it is whatever
so anyways eventually we liked
everything and slowly into being mary j
barge
so we did a black history of special
like six of the girls mary j blige go
bond and another african-american stunt
coordinator
female of course so it was me and her
and they were promoting
changing the dynamics for or bringing
awareness for black women who were stunt
coordinators so
they wanted me to come up with a program
so what are the kind of things that the
girls will be learning
oh my gosh program also just fyi i know
this
program is based in los angeles but it
is also virtual so people in las vegas
can attend
yes we're looking worldwide i love how
stunts test your flexibility
your coordination and your balance have
you ever seen
a person flying backwards and through a
glass or to a
a building that's got propelling
backwards that's called a ratchet so
some of the girls can experience that
the first thing they're going to do is
trips and fall
understanding that trips and falls are
the most important thing or
you do that more often than anything
else a stump performer martial arts
we're gonna be doing
um squibs and also the big
one that we're really doing is basically
we're going out to one of the race
tracks
and the girls we have the opportunity to
be a pastor as one of the drivers do
slides like 180s and
like have a c so that's going to be the
highlight i really think
for more information about this program
visit diamondintheraw.org
and fyi those who are part of it
virtually there will be recordings of
all the activities for
anyone to utilize